if I could rework the entire business
model of google i would get google to
charge for their search engine I think
it's an outstanding product I
acknowledge that I'll say it publicly I
use it all the time too much I don't
have a Google account and very careful
about that I don't have a gmail account
and I don't sign into Google when I use
the google search but Google still knows
me because I am really only on one or
two computers if they're watching they
will they will know Google of course is
always watching but the way to solve
that is that Google the Google search
the Google all the Google products are
free which it means that they have to
read that their revenue is derived from
advertising the alternative would be to
charge me ten dollars a month say for
all I can eat on the google search and
in exchange for that they would say we
will promise never to look at you that
there be no cookies no ways that they
can survey what we're doing they would
do away with themselves as a big day to
come p the same is true of facebook i
don't have a facebook account not
because facebook's a bad product in some
way i think it's creepy but only because
of their data practices if the facebook
product was offered for ten or fifteen
dollars a month or whatever the price
was like Spotify is it would be a much
more attractive model so i think that
that is the challenge I'm not the only
person to think in these terms Ethan
Zimmerman who is a fellow of the Berkman
Center and one of the the most
articulate sort of evangelists for the
Internet at least at the beginning
argues now that the free business model
was the original sin of the internet and
I think Ethan's choice of biblical
language is appropriate it was an
original sin it's corrupted everything
else so I want to see Google charge for
their services and I think that they
could still be an incredibly viable
company after all what's wrong with
paying with stuff before this interview
I paid for my lunch I paid for my taxi
cab I didn't exchange my data for it
that economy has worked well for
hundreds of years this new economy is
creepy it's
Apted by the original sin of swapping
wonderful technology for data